nous démenti weezy l'ogc nice et l'as
magenta c'est demain btg on aimerait la
passer avec une femme et non seul et
triste
donc on va essayer de séduire ariane
voilà c'était un simulateur de rendez
vous romantique
ces partis alors en gros on clique sur
l'image voix live il nous propose un
truc par exemple là il nous dit lui
faire un câlin bas ont valu en ferrain
d'ailleurs up et à chaque fois font
prendre les bonnes de ce zoo jolie
câlins merci à ryadh lui lire un poème
on attendait ce que c'est une fille
facile c'était un joli poème mais merci
c'est gentil a complimenté ses yeux au
tu es mignon elle veut un bisou bouton
quoi trying to mais j'ai perdu fin après
ce que j'ai voulu faire un petit bisou
mais ça y est on a perdu [ __ ] avant
qu'on s'en aille quel âge as-tu pourquoi
tu veux savoir s'habille atx j'aime
sortir avec des hommes plus âgés c'est
ça 18 et plus ça bravo je suis
impressionné voilà c'est ça mais grosse
biatch c'était beau embrasse moi j'aime
ça dans déjà vécu cette scène là en
génie de la musique bon si on va danser
du rock mais je fais comment pour venir
danser avec toi on danse à 10 mètres
d'écart chacun sait ça ans tu sais
comment mettre une ambiance romantique
n'est ce pas l embrasser sur la bouche
un peu trop violent 1 allez on part sur
une nuque alors allons-y éloigne eloi
une telle oeuvre de manu que s'il te
plaît nous revoilà donc là comme ça
qu'est ce qu'on fait on peut embrasser
tout court oh oui voilà lembras et ont
retiré on l'a embrassée on retire la
grand bras si on s'arrête plus bordel oh
tu embrasses bien mais je suis fatigué
donc je te dis juste bonne nuit goodbye
ok fredzone fredzone ça y est c'est fini
pour nous attend mais j'arrive pas à
lire à traire ses [ __ ] de femmes là
encore un poème moi ça marche attendait
elle propose de boire un peu de voir
mais bien sûr comment je fais c'est une
petite cuisine mais elle fonctionne bien
c'est bien bravo
oui ouais ça fais ok elle aime bien
prendre un peu de vent mais pas trop non
plus ah bah voilà je vais faire du steak
pour le dîner au bord de la piscine et
où vous sortez qui est un petit flynn ya
un bon feeling l'armée dramont mood un
bon petit mas rouge va bien avec du
steak convenait l'adorent le vin rouge
que le bois que celle pas sa vie encore
plus tard il fait style n'ont pas trop
mais en vrai à le steak est apparemment
excellent voilà s à un homme puisse
faire la cuisine moi je dis ça je dis
rien quelle est ta favorite mais je sais
pas en fait quoi
elle pose une question je ferai pour m
dit [ __ ] c'est joe de manger de fait
que de parler tu es chiant mais
j'hallucine ariana là tu vas pas faire
ta grande et vous avez compris la blague
tant pis je n'abandonnerai jamais sachez
le
je vais fait boire plus de 20 kt à
l'heure et du coup elle va aux toilettes
alors j'attends non j'ai trop bu pour
faire quelque chose ce soir la fin au
non m'en [ __ ] assuré m'intéressait pas
et tout basij passage
oh est-ce qu'on devrait le boire ici ou
ailleurs donc là elle m'a fait une
petite ouverture pour que j'invite à
dîner mais on se jette dessus comme ça
je connais un bon restaurant mais je
dois m'habiller mieux que ça attends moi
oui mesdames et j'ai suivi dans la
chanson faire exprès vache tu crois
pourra plus tôt psychopathe regarder ce
regard frustré non voilà là j'attends
vraiment dans le couloir oh mon dieu
elle s'est mis en mode cadeaux on va
aller dans ces petits bistrots voilà du
coup j'ai peur je sais pas s'il vient
continue de manger ou lui parlait en
fait non je suis deg j'ai voulu
continuer de manger al'inverse de tellin
m'a dit que j'étais un gros porc tu
pensais qu'à manger
est-ce que cet abus score de la jauge
mange beaucoup [ __ ] voilà c'est bon on
à l'étape d'après j'aime les comédies
c'est quoi tes favorite
moi je me dis battant mais comme
d'ailleurs tu ta question je vais pas
manger et esquiver aux mondiaux une
nouvelle étape
quel est le dernier endroit où tu as
voyages et bouffe non je voulais
vraiment jouer cette fois le pass on va
faire 1 sur 2 1 2 1 2 mais aucune
logique tard yann montcuq arrière j'ai
bavé qu'on peut aller dans une autre
chambre obtint tôt j'ai fait un truc
différent de tout à l'heure ou l'endroit
si j'ai mis la main sur visage comme ça
comme ça apple ça mène on devrait aller
en premier [ __ ] les gars faut être
hyper stratégique surtout pas dans la
chambre nous traiter de gros pervers
dégueulasse on va aller marcher c'est
passé allons marcher dans le parc on va
pouvoir se connaître un peu mieux hausse
est sur la bonne voie pour faire
attention à la fredzone surtout un à
elle veut que je l'aï je la pousse césar
guiffard poche où l'amusement bordel ça
c'est bien pour bien voir ce qu'il ya
sous le tee shirt je parle je parle de 6
un bourrelet par exemple de la grèce
faisait d'un des pervers quoi c'est
incroyable un peu plus tard à l'école je
fais beaucoup de gymnastique j'étais
vraiment bonne à ça je peux attraper les
bars avec mes jambes
même si je porte un gilet mais tu vas te
calmer ça va allez go ça va la patate
c'était vraiment fun
on devrait retourner à l'ab à la maison
alors là qu'est ce qu'on fait [ __ ] on
va aller à la piscine mec
yes j'adore dehors et se soit une
parfaite nuit regarde le ciel on va se
baigner ou quoi l ai nagé ça peut être
fun j'ai un bikini que tu vas adorer
voici un petit coin calme toi et pas la
patate à temps survient dans l'eau
s'écoule ouais je vais avec toi ah c'est
bien ça je vais lancer un défi on va
faire une course une course salaires
phone ok on est en pleine course
regarder la haye à fond je me retourne
et je vois nager sur mon chemin
ça devient dur de retient encore ma
respiration je n'ai plus de respiration
et je vois un gros cul devant moi pas du
tout et je dois aller à la surface pour
avoir un peu d'air à rien elle passe en
dessous moi elle a gagné et du coup elle
veut sortir et bien sûr ton [ __ ]
la moindre erreur ça peut être fatal
vous le savez la gv a donné fin on
devrait aller dehors pour manger non
fois régime et donc je mange non ces
moments passés dans la piscine à devoir
me dire reste la jeune nul puceau pleine
bouche et je vais pleurer à ryad
ariane ok on fera ça mais mais mais
baisse ne pose plus aucune question je
veux plus manger avec toi ok tel
démonter le témoin et carnets [ __ ]
vrai que je mange mais ça marche pas on
regarde non je vais lui parler et un
deal est forte ok le resto plus jamais
je te attend elle pense que je
complément toutes les filles quoi mais
tu ne connais mal moi je suis moi ça
montre samut je devrais complimente non
jetteront complémenter j'aurais pas dû
s'allumer mal à l'aise ou pourrions nous
aller maintenant
go for you drive ça a l'air cool mais
par contre j'ai bu deux verres de vin tu
devrait conduire oui on va aller
ailleurs et dans ce resto pourri où peut
aller en boîte le musée ou la boîte la
boîte coule club est ce qu'on devrait
boire ou dans ses abords à je sais pas
boire je regarde un mec honnête pour
écolo c'est génial tu conduis donc
content de toi d'une seule bière je suis
sam c'est promis vraiment je fais un
homme sérieux rouillard vraiment et je
dis pas ça parce que j'ai envie de
séduire a vraiment aller on va danser on
y est check it baby comme taylor swift
allez on danse encore what do
one of us ça non plus grand de tous les
calmes de la planète mais je lui met un
coup direct prends toi c'est avec dp ok
on s'en va avant qu'une bagarre éclate à
noyal et sécurité khimki moscou de la
boîte
non c'est bon elle a du bon elle a été
virée du club on peut faire autre chose
qui peut l'intéresser
il ya un truc de lingerie je crois j'ai
besoin de nouvelles lingerie aide moi à
voir quelque chose mais avec grand
plaisir bordel de merde je cherche des
sous vêtements pas très cher comme par
hasard un pervers ce fashion et sexy
quelque chose de noir ça devrait être
bien regarder un retour si tu peux me
trouvais ça oh [ __ ] on a chaud entre 4
soutien-gorge travail avait pas de
soutien
c'est scandaleux ça c'est un plus pour
le sport ça sans soutien gorge sans
bretelles un ça se voit et ça c'est un
beau soutien gorge on prend le beau
soutien gorge non mais ça se trouve
vulgaire trouve le gardien c'est un
caleçon pour hommes déjà ça dégage aucun
chanteur string sexy et fashion mais un
peu trop cher je pense que je vais
passer mon truc réessaie non j'ai encore
raté
du coup elle veut aller à la fête
foraine ok on va au parc de l'amusement
et j'en ai c'est le roller coaster way
friends and ouais quoi il se passer là
oui on va faire l'autre attraction au
regarde on va être mouillé pardon du
coup puisqu'elle est mouillé elle veut
rentrer merci c'était cool je te donne
un 7 sur 10
huawei on s'amuse un an [ __ ] c'est
bien ce à quoi elle mange à et qui
apprennent à gérer une crampe trojan
plus cette femme c'est comme je te
disais alors un mois après avoir pris le
métro j'ai la migraine si je bois de
l'eau quoi cela aucun sens et si on va
en jacuzzi en [ __ ] les gars aiment dit
qu'elle ne peut rien promettre mais
allons-y
et on voit où ça nous mène au nom va
jouer à action et vérité tu veux une
vérité ou une action vérité faut pas
dire actions surtout de pervers as tu
déjà eu quelque chose sexuelle dans un
jacuzzi
non est-ce que je pose la même question
quel est ce qu'elle m'a demandé où le
temps tôt elle avait dit non mais une
première fois à tout bordel action
jeumont la facile tu dois m'embrasser a
choisi une action est chaussé d'action
[ __ ] [ __ ] j'ai pris sur tonight show
panique je peux lui demander de retirer
son honore ses morts est le fera pas lui
donner le gage de prendre une douche et
de me laisser regarder beaucoup trop
pervers qu'on va faire l'écart de la
sûreté qu elle m'embrasse non je me suis
mis dans la [ __ ] fredzone je loue faut
absolument j'ai bien retourné à son
droit je vais tenter
allez on va faire action ou vérité tiens
ta respiration aimé ta tête sous l'eau
ok je fais elle a choisi une vérité je
lui pose la question que ma peau et à
l'heure elle me répond exactement la
même réponse on est sur le bon chemin
bordel elle a choisi une action lui dit
de faire un bain de minuit dans sa
piscine c passable ou de retirer son
autant que la piscine et voilà gens
c'est déjà prendre cette vidéo j'espère
que ça vous a plu
je le connais je te calmes la vidéo on
se retrouve très vite un tour elles
peuvent sur la lenteur et puis sociaux
l'enjeu même raconté
fâché le castor est assez rigolo les
blagues sur le pic à kuala là encore
malheureux
[Musique]